All those opposed,
let's get unpredictable.
As you know,
I encourage viewers to call in
and leave us voice mails,
but I never have the time
to listen to them.
Our crew at The Opposition
has put some voice mails
together
that I've never heard before.
Now, obviously, I'm smart enough
to think of the best things
on my own,
but sometimes it's nice
-to have someone help me find
the... -Find the right words.
Just a min... Yeah, just a...
Just a...
It's nice to have someone help
me find the right words, yes.
Here with me is virtual expert
on everything, Kobi Libii.
-(cheering and applause)
-I, um...
I have a surface understanding
of lots of things, Jordan.
Well, that's all you need.
Chuck, let's fire up
the first call.
-(phone beeps) -Hi. My name
is Alex, and I'm from Illinois,
the state where the true
Republicans originated from.
And my question is what are
the tactics I should use
to get the deep state
out of my personal life
and out of the thoughts
that are in my head.
Thank you. Your show
means a lot to me. Bye.
Clearly,
listening to that voice,
I'm assuming he lives
in his mother's basement.
It's pretty clear
from the context
that that's exactly
where he lives, Jordan.
You'd be surprised.
A lot of the deep state
exists in mothers' basements.
They go deep.
-It's... -It's not just how
they pervade the government.
They go subterranean
in your mother's house.
There's something about that.
I haven't put it all together,
but there's something
about this idea
that there's the type of person
who is alone,
-living in a basement
without any outside jobs. -Oh.
They're usually more attuned
to these--
what outsiders would call
"conspiracies"
-and we call "putting the pieces
together." -Absolutely.
I mean, you couldn't be
more right, Jordan.
I mean, these people,
they live alone
with nothing
but their own thoughts
-rattling around in their head
day after day. -Yes.
And for some reason,
the deep state
is targeting those people.
Yes. This is what...
You have--
you have to be careful,
because if you let
other people's thoughts
-inside your head,
-(chuckles)
that's when infection starts.
-That's where the trouble
begins, Jordan. -Yes.
When you start listening
to other people,
you can kiss
your real views good-bye.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm definitely an anti-vaxxer
-when it comes to other ideas
in your mind. -(laughs)
I haven't been persuaded
by a thing another person said
in decades.
(both laugh)
I guess long story short,
keep the other people at bay
and just lock the doors
and hope your mom
doesn't come back downstairs.
-Chuck, let's hear another call.
-(phone beeps)
Hi, Jordan.
This is Liz from Newark,
and I have a question.
I feel like everyone's
so obsessed
with political correctness
these days
that I don't know
what I can say anymore.
So what can I say
without getting in trouble?
That's a...
it's a great question, right?
I feel like, you know,
I'm a bit of a man's man.
-(laughs) That's obvious,
Jordan. -Yeah.
Thank you very much.
(laughter)
I don't know what
the rules are anymore
when it comes to interacting
with women.
Jordan,
you couldn't be more right.
I mean, how many times
have I been on a date,
seen another woman walking by,
complimented that woman,
-then, all of a sudden,
my date's mad! -Yeah.
It's, like, what?
Do-do these feminists want us
to praise women, or do they not?
I guess I should just never talk
to women, huh, Jordan?
-Huh. -Yeah.
I mean, you get up,
you don't pay, you leave her
to pay the bill,
-and suddenly, you're being
offensive? -Absolutely.
Right? Yeah.
You're empowering her to take
control of the situation.
Absolutely! It's like
if you want to have equal pay,
then sometimes you have to pay
for my entire first-date meal.
Yeah. I don't know where
these lines are, snowflakes.
-We're...
-(laughs) Thanks for the call.
We're as lost
as you are, caller.
Let's check out one more call.
-(beep) -Hey, Jordan,
Anthony Scaramucci.
Having trouble sleeping tonight.
I'm a huge fan.
-KLEPPER: Yup. -I love Donald J.
Trump, and I know you do, too.
You know what I love most
about Donald Trump,
is he tweets after he watches
your show, Jordan, okay?
And so, he listens to your show,
goes to sleep,
and in the morning,
he's firing out those tweets
because of you, babe.
So, what do you love
about Donald Trump?
-That's what I'm dying to know.
-Oh.
You know what?
He brings out a good point.
Like, we do have a fan
in the commander-in-chief,
-um, and that's not lost on us.
-Mm.
I think to-to know that somebody
on high watches television,
uh, to perhaps a...
a dangerous amount, uh,
and comments directly
with it is, um...
Frankly, we know that...
that puts us in a position
where there's a lot of power.
We don't want to abuse that.
-No. I mean...
-That would be uncouth for us.
Uh, it would be irresponsible,
you know?
We don't want
to do those things, Jordan.
to do those things.
-But do sometimes.
-We definitely do those things.
Because...
from another perspective,
-Mm-hmm.
-we can.
(laughter)
When I...
I think that's something
-the president understands...
-Mm-hmm.
...is that, uh, people on TV
are on TV,
which must mean
they're important in some way.
And so, even though
you're surrounded with advisers
-and people are who are experts
in policy... -Yeah.
...with a diverse knowledge
-and an awareness of what a...
what a cause is... -Mm-hmm.
...and what those actions
might be...
-Aah! (mutters)
-Um, uh...
(laughter)
But what he does understand is
that those people
don't have television shows.
No, no, they... they don't.
Uh, and, therefore, they don't
know what the (bleep)
-they're talking about.
-Right?
I mean, I for one
have been drunk on power
since the first time someone
pointed a camera in my face.
-Exactly. Mm-hmm.
-You know?
-And that gives me
a credibility... -Mm-hmm.
...that no senior policy adviser
can rival, Jordan.
-Yes.
-You know?
And you--
your name is on the show,
so the cameras are pointing
at you,
and your name's on the show.
So when you speak, you speak
with the weight of authority...
-Yeah. -...unmatched
by any PhD in the land.
-Exactly.
-Mm-hmm.
-You know what? Yeah.
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
(cheers and applause)
Do you want
some dumb Poindexter adviser
who reads all these articles,
or do you want somebody on TV
who just speaks over them?
(laughter)
Thank you for watching,
President Trump,
and thank you, Mooch.
(applause and cheering)
All right, Kobi,
we're running out of time.
But if you'd like to hear
your voice on television,
the best way
to do it is work hard.
There are no shortcuts,
full stop.
The one exception is...
if you call and leave me
a message at:
Ask a question, we'll answer it.
Leave a thought, and
we'll tell you if you're right.